every Tuesday our ion money series looks
at financial issues Americans face this
morning we focus on the housing market
and why fewer people are buying a home
existing home sales in April were down
4.4 percent from a year ago according to
the National Association of Realtors
that is despite lower mortgage rates CBS
News business analyst Jill Schlesinger
is here with how home buyers and sellers
can make the right financial decision
still good morning this is a buyers
market right now absolutely so if you're
a first time home buyer what are the
advantages and the challenges here well
I think the big advantage is that now we
have the shift and there are some more
homes coming on the market so we have a
little bit more inventory so that's a
big advantage also what we know is
mortgage rates as you said really low
the lowest of the year we're down at
around 4% for a 30-year fixed-rate
mortgage the economy is good jobs are
more plentiful but it's still tough to
buy a home because prices are still up
we see price increases slowing down but
for first-time buyers we see that median
price of over 340,000 that does right
and then not even because in many
markets they're not but again and the
inventory for homes under 300,000 has
dried up considerably so first-time
buyers still having a tough go of it
so 13 percent the numbers show the
people lost their homes last year
because of financial problems so how can
you figure out how much you can afford
you know every calculation there are
many calculations there's a good online
calculator New York Times has it there's
plenty of them out there buy versus rent
you want to compare apples to apples
right so don't compare a three-bedroom
house with a studio apartment not the
same but when you run the numbers you're
gonna look at your principal and
interest payment for your mortgage right
you're gonna look at your homeowners
you're gonna look at your property taxes
you're also going to add in maintenance
people always forget that about one to
three percent every single year
something's gonna go wrong in your home
and you've got to add it up you also
want to be clear is owning this house
gonna preclude me from doing other
important pieces of my financial
planning like paying down my student
loans like saving for retirement so
you've got to have a whole picture
it seems like with real estate you're
always there too late right like it's
your brother-in-law it's your kind of
they got the deal great neighborhood so
where should people go now their
particular cities where you can still
find deals pick up areas well first of
all we should note that I know it's not
so easy to pick up and go but there are
some markets where there have been
tremendous values relative to sort of
general affordability of the town so
we're talking about places like Chicago
and Cleveland other areas in Ohio we
know that Philadelphia is a good bargain
but generally speaking when you look at
over the country what you should know is
there is usually a deal in your
neighborhood of choice you're just gonna
have to be incredibly patient to find it
if you're selling by the way this is
primetime right now as an MA
unbelievable because we see that the
biggest premiums over market value occur
in the month of June amazing you get 9.2
percent more than market value sellers
don't forget what's the most important
thing set a reasonable price the first
three months on the market the most
important weeks if you don't get a bike
Tony lower that price because if you
don't get that bite early on yeah the
house is going to be tougher to sell I
love those financial issues we face on
on Tuesdays we're gonna run out of
Tuesday's before we run out of issues to
cover bottomed out there it's the
age-old problem too about renting versus
buying because I was raised in a house
you should always buy if you can yeah
but now Ness is that snot necessarily
the best thing to do no and by the way
older people are becoming 50s and 60s
the largest percentage increase in
renter's is happening at that age group
why is that important because a lot of
people want liquidity they want access
to their money they sell their house
they got the money they rent for a while
all is good as you say you're not you're
not renting you're buying freedom that's
it baby
I love my freedom thanks babe yeah like
that she'll always good happier